nick bilton ne pardonne pas la grc de ne
pas avoir diffusé une alerte public dès
le début du carnage qui a coûté la vie à
sa femme enceinte de leur deuxième
enfant
il devint une autre personne la grc
publie une dizaine de gazouillis durant
les 13 heures que dure la chasse à
l'homme espérant que les médias
d'information prennent le relais il est
évident que ce prix communication le
loerie des conséquences quand même
important en ce qui a trait fatalité
alors qu'ils se déplacent de village en
village le tireur déguisé en policier
rôle dans une fosse autopatrouille si
nous avions su que le tireur se faisait
passer pour un policier jamais ma femme
n'aurait quitté la maison dit nick
bilton la grc avait pourtant été avertis
dès les premières heures du carnage
selon le fils tester le corps de police
choisit cependant de divulguer cette
information que le lendemain des
familles des victimes comme clinton
henson qui a perdu son frère rapporte ap
rick remettent aussi en question
l'opération policière et les effectifs
déployés sur le terrain en europe par
exemple qui est indisponible
on croirait des mais qui malheureusement
n'ont pas été sollicités à ce jour la
grc n'a pas voulu confirmer le nombre
d'agents qui ont été déployés dans la
région
est-ce que d'avoir plus de présence de
policiers sur le terrain
érigé des barrages bloquaient les
bloquer les chemins donner une présence
plus accrue est ce que ça leur ait pu
sauver des vies la tuerie porte à pic
touche aussi personnellement l'agent de
la grc à la retraite louis philippe
thériault six ans avant en juin 2014
il avait été impliqué dans la fusillade
de moncton qui avait coûté la vie à
trois de ses collègues et amis donc
c'est une situation semblable se
reproduire est ici je ne crois pas qu'il
y aura un même chaos
cependant il semble qu'en nouvelle
écosse
il ya eu une certaine confusion trois
mois après la tuerie de portes à piquer
plusieurs manifestations organisées par
des familles une commission d' enquête
indépendante est finalement annoncée par
le gouvernement fédéral j'espère que
l'enquêté publique qui va être mené va
donner des réponses à ces questions là
et que les personnes responsables ont
tenu responsable la commission denquête
devrait publier un rapport préliminaire
en mai 2022 et déposer ses conclusions
en novembre de la même année ici nicolas
steinbach radio canada à moncton